I made this announcement last night on  Sunday April 13th I'm gonna host the MTV  Movie Awards now I don't want to brag  but the story has been picked up by news  stations across the country everyone's  talking about it very exciting the host  of the MTV Movie Awards has been  revealed Conan O'Brien will host the MTV  Movie Awards Conan O'Brien picking up a  new gig Conan O'Brien will be serving up  buckets of golden popcorn and he's  pretty excited about it it's going to be  Austin I gotta tell you I'm so psyched  it's a Greek juice I'm very happy for  him and I'm happy for me too  I think about him and I love him very  very dearly in fact I talk about him in  the book I'm a little skeptical about it  I'd rather not comment on it well shock  when I learned about it but still it's a  spectacularly bad idea I think it's  atrocious  well this is horrific I can't even  imagine it he has no regard for human  life  [Applause]